In this age of CGI, it's easy for filmmakers
to use digital effects instead of actual stunts.
And while the end result might look cool,
it doesn't quite pack the same punch.
However, some of the most incredible movie
scenes involve practical stunts that are so
unbelievable you’d never guess they were
totally real.
Terminator 2: Judgment Day
When it comes to pushing the envelope in special
effects, James Cameron is without a doubt
the king of the world.
But this VFX revolutionary still believes
in using practical effects whenever possible.
After all, we’re talking about the guy who
built an 800-foot Titanic replica and then
sank it in a 5 million-gallon water tank.
However, in Terminator 2, Cameron took his
love for real-life stunts to death-defying
levels.
Near the end of the film, the 3-time Oscar
winner used an actual aircraft during a thrilling
chase where a SWAT van attempts to outrun
a helicopter.
In one stunt, the chopper flies beneath an
overpass at nearly 70 miles per hour.
But with just five feet of room above the
helicopter, the camera crew refused to film
it.
So Cameron shot the sequence himself, pulling
off what's got to be one of the riskiest aircraft
stunts in cinema history.
Speed
Before he was Neo or John Wick, Keanu Reeves
was Jack Traven, a policeman who finds himself
aboard a bus that's rigged to explode if it
drops below 50 miles per hour.
Things get even worse when the bus races up
an elevated freeway, straight toward a 50-foot
gap in the road.
Sandra Bullock’s character, Annie, is forced
to drive the bus straight into the air to
clear the gap, landing safely on the other
side.
The filmmakers digitally removed that missing
chunk of the highway, but director Jan de
Bont actually got the bus to fly.
Using a vehicle that was stripped down to
bare bones, their stunt driver got the bus
up to 61 miles per hour before soaring off
a ramp built on an LA freeway.
"Thank you, thank you very much."
Mission: Impossible II
When it comes to performing his own stunts,
Tom Cruise is miles above nearly every other
actor on the planet.
For proof, look no further than Mission: Impossible
2.
In the opening sequence, Cruise dangles off
the side of a cliff without a safety net.
So when he flings himself from one rock to
another, the only thing keeping him alive
is a thin cable.
Later on, during an insane fight sequence,
Cruise had a steel cable attached to a knife
and positioned himself so it would stop about
a quarter of an inch away from his eye.
It's that kind of dedication that proves Tom
Cruise is worth every cent he makes…and
also that he's totally nuts.
The Bourne Ultimatum
In the third installment of the Bourne series,
secret agent Jason Bourne throws down with
an assassin in what may be the best fight
of the franchise.
But first, Bourne has to leap across an alleyway
and crash through a window.
Rest assured, there's no CGI here, just old-fashioned
practical effects.
Matt Damon’s body double leapt from one
building to another, smashing through a false
window, while another stunt man, attached
to a wire rig, followed with a handheld camera.
Skyfall
The 007 franchise is jam-packed with amazing
stunts, from the parkour sequence in Casino
Royale to the parachute jump in The Spy Who
Loved Me.
But it's pretty hard to beat the motorcycle
chase from Skyfall.
Instead of using a green screen, director
Sam Mendes decided to put actual motorbikes
on actual rooftops in the Middle East.
The stunt drivers maneuvered their bikes down
concrete strips that were about a meter wide.
Bond stunt double Robbie Maddison explained,
"A lot of the rooftops have old air conditioning
units with metal stakes coming up.
Things that can stab you if you were to fall
on them.
It definitely was not a place you'd want to
ride with no helmet."
Iron Man 3
We can all agree that one of the best action
sequences in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
is Iron Man 3's "Barrel of Monkeys" scene,
when everyone aboard Air Force One is sucked
out of the plane.
The freefalling crewmembers form a human chain,
allowing Iron Man to safely deposit them into
the ocean.
Marvel's executives gave their movie wings
— by hiring the Red Bull stunt team for
this sequence.
In total, these diehard adrenaline junkies
made approximately 600 jumps over the course
of eight days, with each dive lasting about
a minute.
While the VFX crew had to take care of adding
certain aspects — like Air Force One, the
"Excellent.
Good team effort, all around.
Go us."
The Fast and The Furious 7 & 8
If you're new to the Fast and the Furious
franchise, you might be surprised to learn
that a lot of the stunts you see on screen
are legit.
Like that scene in Furious 7 where Vin Diesel
and the gang parachute from a plane 12,000
feet in the air — in their cars.
The filmmakers rigged up four vehicles with
parachutes and dropped them from the sky.
Each car was equipped with three cameras,
and three skydivers with helmet cameras also
went along for the jump.
In The Fate of the Furious, the gang zooms
into Berlin, and ends up smashing bad guys
into oblivion with the help of a 14.5-ton
wrecking ball.
For the scene, the stunt drivers doubling
for the good guys had to get out of the way,
but the other driver-less vehicles were towed
at 40 miles per hour, straight into the equally
fast ball of death.
Baby Driver
Director Edgar Wright basically mashed up
Heat, The Driver, and Singin' in the Rain
into one glorious movie.
This 2017 heist flick follows a music-loving
getaway driver who tries to leave his life
of crime after falling head-over-heels for
a charming waitress.
And as it turns out, almost every stunt Baby
pulls off is the real deal.
That includes the jaw-dropping "180 in, 180
out" gag from the movie's opening scene.
Our hero throws his Subaru into a forward
180, spinning around one truck, before throwing
the car into a reverse 180, successfully dodging
another vehicle.
The Baby Driver stunt doubles wanted to capture
that realistic feel, even if it meant putting
their lives on the line.
"Questions?"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!